people assume to ring a bell at the
church is just by pulling one rope and
one bell but our church is different
it's not as easy as it looks
it does feel like a dance to me
[Music]
my name is ocalina patricia lacanoff
gregory and i play the bells at the holy
ascension cathedral here in onalaska
onalaska island is located out in the
aleutian chain between the pacific ocean
and the bering sea
the church is a very iconic place and
wherever you go on this island you could
see it
[Music]
i've been ringing the bells maybe 35
years
to ring the bells we go up a flight of
steep stairs
[Music]
step up onto the platform
and then you put your right foot on the
one big bell your left foot on the other
big bell and then the smaller bells you
twist your hands and then pull them
there are only a handful of other people
that know how to ring the bells there is
no written music i just have to play
them by what i was taught from watching
my dad
my dad has been playing the bells for 60
years
he learned from his godfather i'm
teaching my daughter and then also my
great nieces
[Music]
for me to learn to ring the bells and to
pass on my dad's legacy i think it's
real important
it's an honor of course to be ringing
the bells because you bring it for god
to hear and for the people to hear and
that's important to me
[Music]
you